déjà qu'à niveau vous avez partout sur
les réseaux en ce week-end ah bon alors
allé à marrakech celle ci avec virginie
la styliste est un génie la styliste que
vous connaissez alors un moment vous
voit mettre l'ambiance
et attention c'est très gênant regarder
ce que je vais choisir en fonction de ça
qui va faire une interro surprise mais
c'est quoi
et il y avait là mais géraldine manieca
passé à tête également marrakech
apparemment je vous laisse y avait tous
ces gens là de tpm pc que bien sûr ce
séjour était gratuit 1 je connais un
petit peu les personnes atteintes et
vous montre quelques photos sur un star
sur twitter je connais les délires
est-ce que vous avez payé
oui beaucoup de choses allaient aller
vite c'est apparu on m'a par l'eau
minérale
ah oui l'hôtel tous les repas l'oif à l
aise et l'hôtel l'hôtesse que vous avez
payé l'hôtel oui l'autre l'hôtel
allemand non non mais kelly non mais
dites vous à l'hôtel annoncé on connaît
bien halal alors moi aussi je connais
bien les pétitions bas je paye quand
même le rocher suchard
est-ce que vous avez payé l'hôtel n'ont
été invités par la meilleure amie de
bernard montiel si vous avez payé
l'avion
ah oui mais par contre bah oui tu vas
juré le bas bien sûr oui oui mais c'est
vrai elle arrive elle a payé très cher
c'est vous qui les a invités oui oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous explique marie explique nous
vous savez que j'ai la chance d'aller
souvent là-bas ou pas les rôles et j'ai
dit ah ah ah il a placé alors vous
placer d'autres hôtels l'un sa vie et
sadique wade mamounia si oui mais
mamounia ça vous avez pas d hôtel deux
étoiles sur la vie de ma mère il ne sort
que des fausses menaces et 1500 euros le
est là le sofitel novotel et sofitel
pour lui c est le cas c'est bien le cas
les schwahn c'est comme le formule 1
mais à marrakech calèche one a laissé le
festival c'est un festival i like du
public excusez mon micro marché pas
marre je suis là mais rien au val
c'était un festival électro poker - dont
un électro c'est pour ça qu'elle y est
elle a alors chanté et moi poker parce
que je jouais au poker accord en fait
vous n'avez rien foutu bons mots très
durs
vous pensez que ça c'est une honte
[Rires]